hi everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today i wanted to make
another video on a chess tactic i have
the honor of playing chess with a lot of
you and i've had a lot of games but you
all have sent me that i've analyzed
can't analyze all of them obviously but
i have been able to look at a lot of
different games people have sent me and
there's a lot of different themes and
tactics that I see people mess up a lot
so I'm going to be going over some of
those just to help improve little small
points of your game just to make sure
that you don't make the same mistake
over and over but one of them is when to
pin down a knight and how to develop
your bishop properly and a lot of times
it's very common many times you'll see a
bishop being developed and you pin down
this knight as you can see here once
this D pawn moves this night is going to
be pinned down to this King a lot of
times as well you'll see a bishop
pinning down the knight to a queen even
in this example here I'm just going to
do a few moves if pawn moves b6 let's
say we castle we can also develop
tonight to c3 a lot of different moves
but what I want to focus here on a lot
of times Bishop will come down to g4
this is very common that you see it's
not a bad thing but I do just want to
pull in as you can see here this light
square bishop is pinning down this
Knight to the King here and this bishop
here on g4 is pinning down this knight
to this Queen here on d1 and it's very
common a lot of people like to when they
develop their bishops always pin down a
knight to something they feel like it's
being active and so they feel like it's
what they have to do now again this
isn't a bad thing but I do want to
caution you there are some times that
you want to make sure that you don't
develop your Bishop and pin down the
knight and that's what we're really
going to talk about today
take a look at this example from light
here and as you can see white would like
to be active he's already started to try
to be active on the queenside here and
really he wants to try to find a move to
do here now I'm not really going to talk
about his setup that he has here but I
do want to say a lot of players from
here they don't think that e 2 or D 3 is
very active and so they really want to
get their bishop involved and a lot of
players here I see will bring their
Bishop to g5 because they think that
when they develop their bishop they need
to develop it and pin down this Knight
as you can see here we have a little
problem this Knight here is being
defended by this bishop and the key
problem that we see is our bishop is
undefended
so what black can do hopefully you can
see it here is black can play the move
Knight takes
excuse-me Knight takes on d5
now as you can see here if we take this
bishop on e7 then the knight can come
back and take on e7 and white is down a
pawn and material from that exchange and
there's no real place that white can
play that's going to be good after the
Knight takes on d5 if we take this night
here on d5 with either of our ponds or
even our knight here then the bishops
can go in to come down and take this
Bishop on to five because again this
Bishop on g5 is unprotected so even if
we try Knight takes on d5 then he's
going to come down and take our bishop
on g5 s you can see here black one upon
up the material and that's definitely
not what we want to do in the middle
games we're trying to figure out what
side is going to be aggressive and how
the rest of the game is going to go so
keep in mind here although it's White's
moving you do want to get your bishops
involve your other minor pieces develop
them correctly you always want to make
sure if you're pinning down a knight
that you're pinning it down
to a piece that's not going to end up
losing your material now if we didn't
have this pawn here on d5 then that
wouldn't be so bad so if it's an open
game and you bring your Bishop to g5
that's one thing but if you have in this
case a pawn on d5 or another piece on d5
knowing that this knight can come to d5
and still defend this Bishop on d7 you
definitely don't want to bring your
Bishop to g5 trying to pin down this
knight on f6 let's take a look at our
last example and is here you can see
that black right now is pinning down
White's knight on f3 to the Queen on d1
now white really wants to alleviate this
pin so he's going to bring his Bishop to
e2 as you can see here black originally
did not develop his Bishop to g4 with
this Bishop here on e 2 so he didn't go
against the cardinal rule but keep in
mind even though he was pinning this
knight down the bishop is now on e 2 so
he's going to have to do something and
this is where I see a lot of players
make mistakes later on the game not just
the development move Bishop themselves
but later on they really don't know what
to do once they see the bishop come to
e2 because a lot of players want to
bring their Bishop to g4 but they don't
want to trade off on Knight to f3 and so
they get kind of lost in confusion now
black really needs to keep in mind that
this is the same setup that we talked
about before we have this pawn here on
d4 now that the knight can attack and
still defend this bishop so we really
need to if we're going to move along in
development we really need if we want to
keep our Bishop here on g4 we need to
defend this we could bring our Bishop to
or excuse me our Queen to d7 we could
bring our knight to f6 but we want to
avoid moves like pawn to g6
trying to fee in Quetta our bishop to
the g7 square and then castle on the
Kings side it's a move like this that's
really going to get you in trouble
because now as we talked about before
the
can now come tonight takes on d4 and
we're going to go up in material now
white black has a few options he can
take our pitch upon e2 and we retake
with our knight or if he wants to he can
take with his knight but then again we
take his bishop on g4 again as you can
see is very important that we defended
our Bishop on g4 but instead we played a
move like g6 which was it may have
looked good because you're like okay I'm
gonna fit in cut up my bishop and all
you know then castle on the King side
and I'll be really safe but you really
need to keep in mind that once white
played Bishop to e2 we need to before we
have King safety we need to figure out
how not to lose material so as you can
see here coming back this is going to be
bad for black instead of playing pawn to
g6 as soon as we see this pawn to e2 or
excuse me Bishop to e2 we really need to
have a different game plan so I know
this is minor but hopefully this will
help some of you out as far as when
you're pinning down a knight first win
not to and more importantly if you are
pinning it down just something to think
about if you ever do see this Bishop
come to e2 or it doesn't have to be e2
it can be another square as well but if
you're you're pinning it down and then
this Bishop comes here to make sure that
one either your Bishop is being
protected or to that you don't have a
piece or pawn here on d4 in this
situation obviously the pawn on e5
doesn't really matter because when his
knight takes his knight can't defend
this Bishop on e 2 as well so hopefully
this will help you every little bit and
your chess game that you can improve
will really help you overall so
hopefully all these middlegame
tactics and strategies that I'm going
over some may seem kind of minor to you
but hopefully when you put them all
together in your chess game and you
start to see these things over and over
that it'll really help you improve your
total game so if you haven't already
please subscribe to the channel and I
will see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching